CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION DR. RACHELE WALENSKY.
DR. WALENSKY, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME THIS MORNING.
SO AS YOU KNOW BY NOW, THIS MOVE
SET OFF CONFUSION FOR THE
1.21 MILLION FULLY VACCINATED
AMERICANS.
YOU AND DR. FAUCI AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN TOLD THEM THAT THEY DIDN'T
NEED TO WEAR MASKS ANYMORE.
ALMOST 20 STATES PLUS COMPANIES
LIKE WALENSKY AND STARBUCKS,
THEY ARE LIFTING OR RELAXING
THEIR MASK MANDATES.
SO DID YOU MEAN FOR THIS
GUIDANCE TO RESULT IN STORES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIFTING THOSE
MASK MANDATES?
>> GOOD MORNING, DANA.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A MOMENT
AND PAUSE AND CELEBRATE WHERE WE
ARE IN THIS MOMENT.
CASES HAVE COME DOWN BY ABOUT A
THIRD JUST IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
OUR DEATH RATES ARE AS LOW AS
THEY HAVE BEEN SINCE APRIL OF
2020.
IN FACT, TEENS ARE ELIGIBLE
ABOVE THE AGE OF 12.
SO WE HAVE PLENTY OF VACCINE AND
THE SCIENCE AS YOU JUST CONVEYED
DEMONSTRATES THAT THEY WORK.
SO THAT IS WHAT ALLOWED US TO
MAKE THIS GUIDANCE AT THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL.
THIS WAS A FIRST STEP.
FOUNDATIONAL GUIDANCE.
EVERYTHING IS THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THIS MEANS AT THIS MOMENT
16 MONTHS LATER AS WE THINK
ABOUT OPENING UP.
WE NEEDED TO SORT OF SET THIS
FOUNDATION BASED ON THE SCIENCE
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD
AS THEY MAKE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
AND WE ARE DOING THE HARD WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
>> YEAH, AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU MEAN ABOUT A FIRST STEP, BUT
CAN YOU SEE SINCE THIS IS BIG
NEWS FOR EVERY AMERICAN, CAN YOU
SEE HOW YOUR GUIDANCE, THAT
VACCINATED PEOPLE CAN TAKE THEIR
MASKS OFF BUT REQUIREMENTS FROM
BUSINESSES, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
KEEP THE MASKS ON ARE SENDING A
MIXED MESSAGE?
>> HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
I KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DO THE
HARD WORK.
THIS WAS INDIVIDUAL GUIDANCE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
COMMUNITIES, WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
BUSINESSES.
WE KNOW AT THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
THE VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
MORE THAN ONE-THIRD OF AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
OVER 45% OF ADULTS ABOVE THE AGE
OF 18.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE SAFE WHEN THEY
GET VACCINATED AFTER THEY ARE
FULLY VACCINATED.
THOSE UNVACCINATED WE ARE ASKING
THOSE BUSINESSES TO WORK HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE VACCINES FOR THOSE
PEOPLE SO THAT THEY HAVE TIME
OFF, PAID TIME OFF SO THEY CAN
GET THEIR EMPLOYEES VACCINATED
AND FOR THOSE PEOPLE WE REALLY
ARE ASKING THEM TO GET
VACCINATED OR WEAR A MASK TO
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE.
>> WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING
RELIES ON THE HONOR SYSTEM FOR
UNVACCINATED INDIVIDUALS TO WEAR
MASKS.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS UNION LEADER SAID ON CNN
THIS WEEK ABOUT THAT.
>> THEY WERE ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
VERBALLY ABUSED AND IN SOME
CASES PHYSICALLY ABUSED BY SOME
OF THE CUSTOMERS.
SO NOW WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT SOMEBODY HAS BEEN VACCINATED
OR NOT, AND YOU ARE GOING TO
CHANGE THEM FROM THE MASK POLICE
TO THE VACCINATION POLICE.
>> WHAT IS THE REMEDY FOR THIS
IN YOUR VIEW?
SHOULD BUSINESSES TRY TO TELL
WHO IS VACCINATED AND WHO IS
NOT?
OTHERWISE, IT'S A FREE FOR ALL,
AS YOU HEARD DESCRIBED.
>> YEAH, SO, FIRST, I WANT TO
CONVEY THAT WE ARE NOT SAYING
THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO TAKE OFF
THEIR MASKS IF THEY ARE
VACCINATED.
IT'S BEEN 16 MONTHS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING PEOPLE TO MASK AND
THIS IS GOING TO BE A SLOW
PROCESS.
THE OTHER THING IS EVERY
COMMUNITY IS NOT THE SAME.
NOT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE
VACCINATION RATES THAT ARE HIGH.
AND SOME COMMUNITIES STILL HAVE
CASE RATES THAT ARE HIGH.
THESE DECISIONS HAVE TO BE MADE
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL.
BUT WHAT WE ARE SAYING TO THOSE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IS THAT IF
THOSE WORKERS ARE VACCINATED,
THEY ARE SAFE.
SO IT'S REALLY WE ARE REALLY
ASKING THE BUSINESSES TO WORK
WITH THEIR WORKERS T
WORD, EVERY GUIDELINE, AND SO
THIS WAS A BIG ONE.
AND EVEN THE LOCAL BUSINESSES
ARE RELYING ON YOU AND YOUR
GUIDANCE TO DECIDE WHAT TO DO
AND HOW TO FUNCTION.
>> AND I COMPLETELY ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
MY JOB AS THE CDC DIRECTOR,
WHICH I PROMISED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHEN I TOOK IT, IS THAT I
WOULD DELIVER THE SCIENCE TO
THEM AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEM
AS WE HAD IT.
WE HAD TWO STUDIES THAT WERE
PUBLISHED THE WEEK PRIOR TO
LAST.
A MAJOR STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
MMWR ON FRIDAY THAT DEMONSTRATES
THAT VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
NOW WE HAVE THE HARD WORK TO DO.
THIS WAS THE FIRST BUILDING
BLOCK.
WE, AS A SOCIETY, HAVE THE HARD
WORK TO TO AS WE AT CDC ARE
DOING THAT WORK TO SAY WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN IN THE WHOLE PLETHORA
OF SETTINGS THAT WE HAVE IN
CHILD CARE SETTINGS, RETAIL
BUSINESSES, IN SCHOOLS, IN
CAMPS, IN TRAVEL.
WHAT DOES THAT FOUNDATION, THAT
SCIENCE THAT WE DELIVERED ON
THURSDAY MEAN FOR ALL OF THESE
OTHER SETTINGS.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT A
SCENARIO THAT DR. LEAN A NGUYEN
WROTE ABOUT IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
SHE SAID, LET'S SAY YOU GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE.
IT'S CROWD AND.
PERHAPS EVERYONE IS VACCINATED.
PERHAPS NOT.
WHAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE CHILD
CARE SO YOU HAD TO BRING YOUR
KIDS ALONG?
THEY DIDN'T CHOOSE TO REMAIN
UNVACCINATED.
THE SHOTS AREN'T AVAILABLE FOR
THEM.
IT'S NOT FAIR TO PUT THEM AT
RISK.
SO LET'S JUST GET PRACTICAL
HERE.
IS IT SAFE FOR THAT UNVACCINATED
CHILD, EVEN IN A MASK, TO BE IN
A GROCERY STORE WHEN PEOPLE
AROUND THEM COULD BE UNMASKED
AND NOT FOLLOWING THE HONOR
SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
VACCINATED?
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
WE WERE GOING TO BE AT THIS
PERIOD OF TIME, WE KNEW THAT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE A TIME
WHERE WE HAD THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS WHO WANTED TO BE
VACCINATED AND YET THE CHILDREN
WERE NOT GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE.
YET.
AND WE ARE WORKING HARD.
LET'S CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT
THIS WEEK WE ALSO GOT NEWS WE
CAN VACCINATE OUR 12 TO
15-YEAR-OLDS.
WE HOPE BY THE FALL WE WILL HAVE
VACCINE KIDS, ELIGIBLE AT
YOUNGER RANGES.
WHAT WE ARE SAYING IS THOSE KIDS
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WEAR A MASK
IN THOSE SETTINGS.
WE RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGE OF
PARENTS WHO CAN'T LEAVE THEIR
KIDS AT HOME, SHOULD BE MASKED
IN THOSE SETTINGS AND KEEP A
DISTANCE.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THOSE
SETTINGS HAVE NOT CHANGED.
>> AND DO YOU TRUST THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT VACCINATED, GIVEN
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN THE PAST YEAR
PLUS, WILL ACTUALLY KEEP THEIR
MASKS ON?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT INCLINED TO WEAR A
MASK WERE NOT INCLINED TO WEAR A
MASK BEFORE THURSDAY.
>> SOME WERE MANDATED TO DO SO
AND THOSE MANDATES ARE BEING
LIFTED IN PART BECAUSE OF YOUR
NEW GUIDELINES.
>> WHAT WE ARE SAG TO SAY, IN
TERMS OF THE HONOR SYSTEM,
PEOPLE HAVE OBJECT HONEST WITH
THEMSELVES.
YOU ARE PRO PEKTED IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED.
>> TO FOLLOW UP ON SOMETHING YOU
SAID ABOUT CHILDREN 12 --
YOUNGER THAN 12.
YOU SAID THE FALL OR THE END OF
THIS YEAR IS THE TIMELINE
CHANGED BECAUSE THINGS SEEM TO
BE MOVING PRETTY RAPIDLY.
>> NO, THE TIMELINE HASN'T
CHANGED.
A LOT OF THIS IS HOW MANY CASES
THEY HAVE, WHAT THE ENDPOINTS
ARE.
NOT ALL OF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ACCURATE LIE
PREDICT.
I AM HOPING BY THE END OF 2021.
>> OKAY, KIDS IN GENERAL, SUMMER
CAMPS, YOU KNOW, AS PARENTS
MAKING PLANS FOR CAMPS FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
CDC GUIDELINES RIGHT NOW STILL
REQUIRE DISTANCING AND MASKS AT
ALL TIMES, INCLUDING OUTDOOR
SPORTS.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS FOR EATING,
DRINKING, SWIMMING, AND
SLEEPING.
WHAT SHOULD AMERICANS EXPECT
WHEN IT COMES TO SUMMER CAMP
GUIDANCE?
WILL THERE BE NEW GUIDANCE AND
HOW QUICKLY WILL IT HAPPEN?
>> YEAH.
SO, FIRST, I WANT TO SAY WITH
REGARD TO SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE
HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT SCHOOLS, WE HAVE ASKED THE
SCHOOLS -- WE WILL NOT BE
CHANGING OUR GUIDANCE FOR THE
END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
MOST KIDS WILL NOT BE VACCINATED
OR FULLY VACCINATED BEFORE THE
END OF THE YEAR AND WE WILL WORK
ON UPDATING THE SCHOOL GUIDANCE.
THE POINT ABOUT CAMPS IS
IMPORTANT.
SO MUCH EVOLVED IN THIS WEEK,
BOTH WITH THE GUIDANCE WITH
UNMASKED IF YOU ARE VACCINATED
AS WELL AS THE ELIGIBILITY OF
VACCINATION FOR 12 TO
15-YEAR-OLDS.
SO WE HAVE TO RAPIDLY UPDATE OUR
CAMP GUIDANCE AND WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> OKAY.
AND YOU SAID ON PBS THIS WEEK,
QUOTE, WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND
IS FOR THOSE WITH IMMUNE
COMPROMISING CONDITIONS AS WELL
AS REALLY ANY OTHER CONDITIONS
THAT AFFECT YOUR HEALTH THAT PUT
YOU AT HIGH RISK FOR DISEASE
THAT YOU CONSULT YOUR DOCTOR
BEFORE YOU TAKE OFF YOUR MASK.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT YOU MEAN?
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE OBESE, PEOPLE WHO ARE
REGULAR SEASON, HAVE DIABETES?
>> SO FOR THE MOST PART THE
STUDIES THAT ARE EVOLVING NOW
ARE FOR PEOPLE WHO
IMMUNOCOMPROMISING CONDITIONS OR
MEDICATIONS THAT INTERRUPT THEIR
IMMUNE SYSTEM.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD TRANSPLANT,
ARE ON CHEMOTHERAPY.
THERE HAS BEEN OIN STUDY THAT
DEMONSTRATES IF YOU ARE ON A
DIALYSIS PATIENT, THAT YOU MAY
NOT BE AS WELL PROTECTED AT ALL
AS WELL.
SO WHAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CERTAINLY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
IMMUNE COMPROMISING DISEASES OR
ON THOSE MEDICATIONS TO CONSULT
THEIR PHYSICIANS.
AGAIN, NOT EVERYBODY HAS TO RIP
OFF THEIR MASKS BECAUSE OUR
GUIDANCE CHANGED OR THURSDAY.
SO, YES, IF YOU ARE CONCERNED,
PLEASE DO CONSULT YOUR PHYSICIAN
BEFORE YOU TAKE OFF YOUR MASK.
>> IF YOU WERE A PREGNANT WOMAN,
WOULD YOU KEEP YOUR MASK ON?
>> WE ARE ENCOURAGING PREGNANT
WOMEN TO GET VACCINATED.
WE HAVE INCREASING DATA THAT
PREGNANT WOMEN SHOULD GET
VACCINATED.
THAT'S GOING TO REALLY BE AN
INDIVIDUAL BY INDIVIDUAL
DECISION.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, IT REALLY JUST
DEPENDS HOW MUCH RISK YOU ARE
WILLING TO TOLERATE, HOW HARD IT
IS FOR YOU TO WEAR THAT MASK.
HOW MUCH DISEASE IS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY FULLY
VACCINATED INDIVIDUAL WHO DIED
OF COVID-19?
>> WE DO KEEP A TRACK OF THIS ON
OUR WEBSITE.
WE ARE ASKING HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES TO SEND
US CASES OF WHAT WE'RE CALLING
BREAKTHROUGH INFECTIONS.
THEY OCCUR.
THEY ARE RARE.
WE ARE AWARE OF 223 AS OF MAY
10th THAT ARE AMONG THE 115
MILLION PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED BY THAT TIME.
I ALSO WANT TO CONVEY THAT NOW
MANY, MANY HOSPITALS ARE
SCREENING PEOPLE FOR COVID WHEN
THEY COME IN.
SO NOT ALL OF THOSE 223 CASES
WHO HAD COVID ACTUALLY DIED OF
COVID.
THEY MAY HAVE HAD MILD DISEASE
BUT DIED, FOR EXAMPLE, OF A
HEART ATTACK.
>> YOU YOU SAID 223 CASES, BUT
NO CONFIRMED DEATHS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE VACCINATED --
>> 223 --
>> GO AHEAD.
>> SORRY.
THERE HAVE BEEN 223 DEATHS OUT
OF 115 MILLION.
>> GOT IT.
>> PEOPLE --
>> THANK YOU.